- [Man] Hey Gary. You talk
a lot about 51-49.
- Yeah.
- Giving more than
you're getting.
For the longest time,
I did not do that.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And do you have any
advice on beside just--
- [Gary] Have you started?
- Have I started?
- When you said
for the longest time
I did not do that,
does that, were you alluding
to you started doing
a little bit of that
or you're thinking
about doing it?
- Yes, for a while now I've been
giving more than I'm getting--
- And what's happening?
- It's a lot better.
The question is
do you have any tips in
speeding that process up?
- Nope.
(laughter)
- [Man] Just patience.
Alright, thanks, man.
'Preciate it.
- But you know it's cool, right?
Of course, dude,
'cause it's the right thing.
You seem pretty fit.
You have any advice on how
to get fucking abs in one day?
(laughter)
That's actually, you know,
it's funny I made one video,
I'm about to get really,
I'm about to
really go hard at
the fitness industry.
The contradiction between
the business and the actual
skills to get into shape,
they talk nothing about
tried and true like
eat well, workout every day
and results happen.
But then on the business
side they're like,
"Alright, what's the fucking
speed up mechanism?"
It's just patience and
it's by the way,
you know what pisses me off
about this conversation
in a different level,
you're young.
How old are you?
(laughter)
If you fucking were patient
as shit for the next 14 years
you'd be my age.
Patience.
And again, I did it.
From 20 to 30,
I built a business from
$3 to $65 million and I was
paying myself $47,000 a year.
That's real patience.
It was a room of guys,
in your 20s and 30s
where that money,
where I could paid myself
a million a year,
where that money is
the leverage to do things that
makes us want what we have
which is girls and
friends and fun,
I was the singular most patient.
Because I knew every dollar
that I would have taken out
to go to Vegas and
have a fun time
was a dollar I wasn't
putting into my business
to make more later.
And I was like, I'm 20.
I'll be 30. Right?
But I had to punt certain things
and maybe even
too much in hindsight.
Maybe a couple of trips to Vegas
would have done me some good.
But, dude, you're 26.
By the way, this is the only,
the second you
make it go faster,
the second you go 49-51
is the second it
stops coming in.
(hip hop music)